I have some delightfully cringe-worthy video
for you today.
I almost fell off my chair.
I cringed so hard when I saw this.
Fox news did a segment.
This was part of Fox and friends.
Apparently they brought on a conservative
squad, and by that they
mean a right wing response to the squad of
actual members of Congress, all of whom are
members of the democratic party and of diverse
backgrounds.
Fox news is conservative squad is not of diverse
It's for congressional candidates who are
running to socialism among other things in
the United States.
They want to be the anti squad effectively.
Now you'll hear the host name of the candidate,
so I won't, this is maybe the dumbest thing
I've heard on a few levels, which we're going
to discuss shortly.
At first I was convinced this was a Saturday
night live parody, but it's not.
The women are all, uh, um, obviously white,
presumably so-called Christians, and it is
actually difficult to watch because this doesn't
appear to be a parody.
They actually seem to be serious here.
Let's take a look.
Publican Alabama congressional candidate Jessica
Taylor joins us now with the conservative
squad.
We have Minnesota congressional candidate,
Michelle Fischbach, South Carolina congressional
candidate, Nancy mace and Texas congressional
candidate.
That's van Dyne.
Thank you ladies for being with us.
Jessica, congratulations.
You actually did this.
Yes, ma'am.
When you up these ladies that want to form
a conservative squad with you, what goes through
your mind?
You know, I'm just honored that they want
to join in this fight and that's exactly what
it is.
You know, we are losing the younger generations
of this country and I'm so grateful that they're
willing to join up and helping this cause.
Okay.
Michelle, why did you want to be a part of
the squad?
You know, this is about bringing the conservative
message to the people of the United States
so that people understand that we're looking
at do nothing.
Democrats, they're obsessing about impeachment
and not really doing anything for the people
of the United States anymore.
You know, you take a look at Western Minnesota,
the district that I live in, and they're,
they're ignoring us.
MCA, they finally gotten around to it a year
later, but the farmers out in Western Minnesota
need us MCA and they waited and waited, but
they have plenty of time for impeachment and
the sham that that is.
And they just continue to obsess about that
and not do the things that the people of the
United States really neat.
These are the types of talking points that
only work in the media equivalent of like
a medical clean room or maybe better said
a media safe space.
We are losing the younger generation.
Well, yeah.
Republican policy has destroyed the earnings
potential and savings potential of the younger
center generation.
College costs have exploded.
The students and the younger people are riddled
with student debt.
Wages are stagnant and they don't have healthcare,
so yeah, you're going to lose young people
as a result of that.
The do nothing.
Dems, they say, well, Democrats don't control
the Senate and between Mitch McConnell and
Donald Trump's veto power at the white house,
they can do very, very little farmers are
struggling and we really need us.
MCA, well, the farmers are struggling because
of Donald Trump's trade policy.
They don't mention that.
Of course, every single one of these dumb
talking points would be dismantled instantly
and anything but a safe space and they are
being held up.
These four women as some kind of moral right-wing
crusaders and it gets even worse.
Let's continue the video.
Nancy, why is the squad important to you?
Well, you know, if I look at my life, I got
my start as a, as a waitress at waffle house.
I became the first woman to graduate from
the Citadel, the military college of South
Carolina 20 years ago.
Today I'm a business woman in state lawmaker
for the United States Congress.
And this is about our future.
This is the American dream.
And you see the Democrats, they've taken a
sharp left turn, um, under the influence of
the socialist squad.
And you look at us and this is socialism versus
American values of freedom and job creation.
And we all understand up here today that people
flourish under freedom and 2020 next year
is pivotal for our country.
And you know, we see so many women across
the country right now, Republican women who
are picking up the mantle and want to serve.
They say, enough is enough.
My kids and my country are worth fighting
for.
And that's what this is about essentially.
Beth, how about you?
Well, I look at where it now we really do
have a Congress.
It's run by extremists and it's dangerous
for America because they're not doing anything.
We haven't seen solutions for out of control,
healthcare costs.
This is not socialism versus anything.
There are almost no socialists in the United
States in prominent positions of power at
the national level.
Uh, the idea that the squad or the democratic
party or Democrats or whoever are pushing
socialism is ridiculous.
This is a false debate.
The country has not gone hard left the country
increasingly realizes that the things that
they have in other capitalist countries like
Norway and Finland, Denmark, Canada, Australia,
Sweden, things like healthcare and education,
we should also have, and as a rich country,
we can also afford to have, that's not socialism.
That's not far left.
This reminds me of Trump's last state of the
union address.
You might remember Trump, uh, yelled out at
the last state of the union.
I think it was the last one, maybe the previous,
but I'm pretty sure it was the last, he yelled
out too much Republican.
Applause in the crowd.
We will never be a socialist nation.
There's no risk of that right now to say ever.
Nobody knows what could happen in a long time,
but who is trying to make this a socialist
country?
I get it.
There are some socialists.
Okay, but actual socialists in positions of
power are few and far between.
They're not making policy.
They are, you know when you talk about tuition
free college paid out of taxes where people
who get really rich from their businesses
pay more.
That's a capitalist thing that happens in
socialism.
You wouldn't have those ultra rich people
except when the socialist state is a corrupt
state, in which case you would and that happens,
but then they probably wouldn't be paying
high taxes.
Single payer healthcare is a capitalist idea
where the fruits of capitalism are used to
make sure everyone has health care regardless
of whether they can personally afford it based
on the job that they have.
They are setting up this fake enemy of socialism
when they are really fighting more progressive
capitalists.
That's really the majority of what the, the
ideas are that they claim to be fighting.
As far left, it's total cringe.
But the really scary thing about this, the
thing that is depressing is that in a lot
of parts of the country, this stuff probably
is appealing.
I understand that as someone who lives in
Massachusetts, I laugh when I see stuff like
this, but because it seems almost like a parody,
but there are parts of the country where folks
like these could actually win.
And we need to be activating and organizing
against them because otherwise they will win.
And even if it's a fake war against socialism
that they think they're waging, they can still
be successful as long as they prevent serious
progressive reforms from actually taking place.
So I know that we laugh it off in a lot of
parts of the country and we joke, and this
is a Fox news echo chamber.
These folks are never going to get elected.
Nobody's going to fall for the false, uh,
the, the straw men that they are putting together.
That's not true in a lot of parts of the country.
This stuff resonates.
And sadly, I mean even here in Massachusetts
and some of them more rural parts, you see,
um, a sympathy for this type of ideology.
So we've got to fight every district.
We've got to fight every race, we've got to
fight all the way to and through the November
of 2020 election if we want a shot at this
because this, they are tricking people, they
are convincing people.
And as scary as it is a, as laughable as it
is also in many ways we've got to fight it
at every opportunity.